hey movie retrospective time yeah
finally getting around to doing this
classic movie this sorry about this but
it kept getting like push back on the
schedule but I finally like said well I
have to do it this month because one of
our listeners Dominick sent me the Blu
ray yeah it's like a deluxe blu-ray yeah
that has all the extras and stuff on
there yeah so it's really really cool
and this is like probably one of my
favorite horror movies in from the 80s I
mean because I'm a huge Clive Barker fan
this is of course Hellraiser now this
came out in 1987 there had been a few I
mean Clive Barker it's very funny like
watching the the documentaries there's
actually a really good it's a two-part
documentary called Leviathan about the
making of Hellraiser and hellbound
Hellraiser 2 and it's about I think each
one is like an hour and a half long and
it's on the blu-ray it's also on shudder
if you have that so both parts are up
there if you want to watch them but it's
just like funny watching the documentary
isn't like watching all the [ __ ] you
know seeing all the photos like from the
you know the filming of this because
Clive Barker looked like a [ __ ] kid
he was like so [ __ ] young you know
what I mean
so I feel like you know he was known as
a writer but you know a few of his
things had been adapted to the screen
but he wasn't really happy with how they
turned out I mean because if you've read
any of Clive Barker stuff and even
subsequently like it doesn't translate a
lot of it trans doesn't translate that
well to the scene it's like not as to
the screen looks like not as cool as
yeah didn't Clive Barker have something
to do with a story behind raw head Rex
yeah yeah and raw head Rex we liked it
at the time but you watch it now you
[ __ ] you know it's just silly as [ __ ]
yeah it was a terrible movie
terrible movie but at the time there was
something about it you can get away with
a lot more back in those days you guys
we were just hungry for more horror
movies to watch yeah to rent a [ __ ]
blockbuster and when when I saw that
[ __ ] demon cover that that [ __ ]
medieval demon with that head piss on
that priest and he's going back eyes me
told the whole [ __ ] movie that for me
and all my buddies
like this shit's epic and that's really
all we remember to that and a downed in
an Irish Church there was a
stained-glass window with a [ __ ]
devil in it yeah and that nobody's
thought that was strange in the church
it's like yeah I'm looking at all masks
cool yeah I want that for my room you
know I kind of [ __ ] like that from yeah
I want I want that I want that window in
my room yeah now that you mention it I
feel like rah had Rex that really needs
a remake because I feel like that's such
a cool idea for a story yeah if it could
be done correctly like without that
goofy looking demon with like the weird
googly eyes or whatever um you know it's
a good concept it's just and I think
that happened with a lot of Clive Barker
stuff that a lot of his ideas are really
good and like his books are really good
but it's like when they try them when
they try to execute it and it's not like
for the same reason that Stephen King
stuff right for a while didn't work on
screen I mean I think that's kind of
like gone by the wayside now because
they've been submitting a tweet but we
love that [ __ ] raw head rex monster
our scans were so much lower back then
oh yeah
pumpkin head kind of ruined it well
pumpkin head was so much better awesome
we need to do that ya know but we can't
we kind of thought raw head rush kind of
looked kind of cool but we expected
things to look fake yeah it's like yeah
different frame around different for
every reference now I should say though
that so so Hellraiser um you know Clive
Barker he'd had a few like adaptations
of his stuff done and he really wasn't
happy with it so he's like well I want
to direct you know my own movie now he
didn't really have any experience like
doing that he said he famously like
showed up on the set and he's like he's
like at least like everybody in the crew
and [ __ ] like that were like patient
because he's like I didn't know one lens
from another and I didn't really know
what I was doing that said though I I
mean I think this is probably easily the
best Steve the best Clive Barker
adaptation this in Candyman which we've
already reviewed I've heard Midnight
Meat Train is good too but I haven't
seen that one yet like I feel like
that's got kind of mixed reviews
I'd have to say visually though and just
the way it's shot and
and I would have to say Candyman is
better but in terms of Yanam in the way
it was shot in the way it was made the
quality I think it looked more style
yeah this is a good good movies about
its type though
you know I mean Hellraiser yeah it's not
bad I'm yes man I think Candyman was a
little bit better in the way it looked
that's just by memory it was a different
yeah it was directed by someone else so
it was like a different you know they
had a different like a person - it had
the colors a little bit better and the
shot composition is everything I
remember him looking really good yeah
because they had like those high up like
those drawn shots and so it wasn't a
drunk shot back then it was a crying
yeah this one this one it gets the job
done
Hellraiser got the job done it wasn't
super artistic the way it was but I
guess it was it's just not as yeah I
mean I think the what this movie ended
up doing I mean you have to imagine this
came out in 1987
now horror movies were very much in the
forefront there were a lot of really
popular ones that had come out like that
year and a couple years prior but it
seemed like a lot of the kind of you
know horror movies that people
remembered are ones that were doing
really well at the box office were kind
of funny you know and I mean like you
had like a lot there was like a lot of
humor and a lot of kind of over-the-top
gore and stuff that's what I like so I
yeah and I like that too but I feel like
the cool thing about Hellraiser was that
it was a very serious horror movie when
no one was really doing that and it was
also you know now it looking back on it
because we've seen pretty much
everything in horror movies nowadays but
in 1987 this was like a really original
vision I mean nobody had made a movie
that looked like that that made like
that had the villains that looked like
that like the Cenobites
I mean it was just and even like the
whole story of it of like this really
weird and like a lot of the people on
the crew said this - it's like
essentially this is a [ __ ] up love
story because what you know the main
character of Julia she's essentially
she's trying to kill people to put flesh
back on her [ __ ] buddy yeah [ __ ]
because she is so like her husband's
brother yeah who was she cuz she was
like so obsessed with him like she had
this
like weird fucked-up obsessive love with
him that she is willing to kill random
dudes or even like her own family
members yeah to put flesh back on him so
she can get the D once again I hadn't
seen this one in a long long time not
even kind of forgotten what year it came
out in you know I mean you said 87 I
remember when we were watching and I was
like no way couldn't Bend yeah he argued
with me it was 87 thought I saw him in
high school but I actually saw it when I
got out of high school left Brazil and
went back to the United States I was
living in Michigan is hanging out with
my friends for the summer before they
went off to college this is before I
joined the army and that's when we saw
it we rented it
we were playing master-blaster and [ __ ]
on NES and I like that crap you know and
watching it again it's still a good
movie but a lot of a lot of the impact
this movie made had a lot to do with the
timing of this movie yeah when it came
out it was doing stuff m'as kind of
revolutionary in a way it was very story
heavy and like you said it had kind of a
serious tone to it
I remembered watching it back then
thinking that the only thing that it
reminded me of was it kind of reminded
me a video drum yeah in those days I can
yeah I can see that but looking at it
now it's kind of slow paced by today's
standards and I remember really being
intrigued by these Senta bites I was
like man cuz he didn't really tell you
much about him yeah they just appeared
they didn't get him a lot of screen time
they were had a very ominous appearance
to them and that was kind of like the
beginning of that kind of gothic
industrial
cyber look they started to come in the
goth scene a couple years later you know
I mean I think that kind of the way they
were dressed kind of helped that look
that ended up becoming what you saw in
the matrix in a way yeah long black
stuff and you know like shiny type [ __ ]
and it kind of had a BDSM vibe to it
but it was just it was just a weird
movie to see you know back then that's
what I mean it really kind of came out
and blew the doors off and like I said
not only because it was like a serious
toned horror-movie that was essentially
a domestic drama with sadomasochism and
more
I mean you hadn't really seen anything
like that or anything like that done in
a way that was like being serious that
wasn't like kind of over-the-top or
stupid or silly or done for laughs so so
from that point of view it's like really
hard to overstate how revolutionary it
was at the time because really nobody
had seen anything like that yeah I'm
going back in time me and my book made
me and my buddy Steve and Jason when we
were watching it we kind of made we kind
of put this in the same like in the same
group is like from beyond and reanimate
her but a more serious we can't thought
it was a little bit like something like
from beyond but and Videodrome we liked
it we liked it it was pretty good but I
you know it's funny is that I remember
when we saw it afterwards we'd be asking
a bunch of questions about their center
bites and we mostly focused on that yeah
because it didn't quite give you enough
they don't remember part two came out
and that was pretty good
I actually quite liked yeah well razor -
yeah and then I remember like three came
out or remember anything about three is
remembered like it started to fall apart
for me yeah I think I'm sorry I stopped
watching them I didn't even realize that
there have been ten of these movies so
there were nine sequels to the
foundation realizing um Doug Bradley the
guy that famously played pinhead who
wasn't called pinhead in the first movie
he was just called lead Cenobite you
know he he got called pinhead by the
fans and then the name stuck but um that
wasn't a Clive Barker invention but he
was in I think up until the seventh or
eighth one and then they had to get
somebody else but the funny thing about
this movie this is kind of the thing
that happens with all these types of
things like I said I remember reading a
lot of Clive Barker's stuff when I was a
kid and that's kind of what made me I
mean I've read Stephen King and you know
a lot of the classics and stuff but his
writing was what made me want to be a
writer because like his imagination is
just [ __ ] crazy and it's just like
[ __ ] the [ __ ] he comes up with in his
stories I had never read anything like
before and it's like you know not only
can he [ __ ] right he also is like an
amazing artist and he can do all this
other [ __ ] so he's kind of like this
Renaissance man and he was so he had
been working with this theater group and
he wrote the novella that Hellraiser was
based on which is called the hellbound
heart which is actually pretty good and
it's very similar to the movie I think
he actually wrote it with the intention
of turning it into a film which is why
there's not that much difference so he
was kind of trying to shop it around
eventually because he wanted to direct
it because like I said you know they had
been doing some you know adaptations of
his stuff and he didn't really like the
way they were coming out so he wanted to
do something of his own vision so they
were able to get I think at first they
were gonna get like remember Richard
Branson he they did virgin films for
awhile they were like funding yeah yeah
now they initially said he was gonna put
up the money to do it and then that kind
of fell through and they decided they
weren't gonna do movies so I think they
got new world pictures amazingly and I
had forgotten about this and I was
watching the movie again and like you
know checking out how [ __ ] badass the
special effects are still this movie
costs less than a million dollars today
you never know by looking at you would
never know I mean some of the effects
like near the end um
you know especially thing like with the
dragon creature in the fire and
everything that looks a little hokey but
that was just because that was kind of
like tacked on at the end and the like
they didn't really have a lot of time to
do it but especially I mean the whole
set piece of I mean I was watching it
again the other night and I hadn't seen
it for like a few years the whole part
where you know the the blood drips on
the attic floor and Frank you know
skinless Frank starts emerging out of
the floor I was like holy [ __ ] I forgot
how [ __ ] good that looks
and like it's like you know his little
brain is there on the floor and it's
like going like veins crawling it's like
in this little spine goes into it those
chunky thing and then like the whole
[ __ ] with like him slowly like as Julia
starts like picking up randos bars and
like slaughtering them in the attics for
him to feed on and get his skin back and
just the whole like um you know the
whole process of him getting the skin
put back on it's just it looks [ __ ]
great it really does I mean still
nowadays
now the same guy that played the played
Frank in human form like in the
flashbacks and stuff that is not the
same guy that played skinless Frank
because they needed a super super skinny
guy so that's one thing that I thought
was really weird and I had forgotten
about this until I was worried watching
it is a lot of the voices were dubbed
over now the the one that they did the
reason they did that for Frank like I
said was because it was two different
actors playing him so they wanted like
the same person
boy's voice you know which makes sense
but the weird thing too is that
initially I mean Clive Barker is British
he's from Liverpool and so the story was
an English story you know so it was set
in England and for whatever reline Oh
for whatever for whatever reason but
it's like the producers new world
pictures were like no we don't really we
don't really want this to be British
because Americans won't watch British
professor something which that was a
weird thing man yeah these are old guys
thinking this because I think that might
have been the situation back in the 60s
yeah
like I'm a it was a little harder back
in the 60s and 70s to sell movies but
the people who were buying these in 87
were mostly teenage guys you know yeah
and people renting it from Blockbuster
didn't give a [ __ ] where that movie came
from no as long as Doria had - yeah and
had some badass monsters in it matter of
fact you know being British it would
have been a bonus like Raw had Rex we
liked it because it was kind of like
happening in Ireland yeah so you know we
were mostly you know Anglo Americans
mostly kind of like Irish Americans you
know really you know she probably did a
DNA test that's probably would all come
back from so we all kind of had like
Irish heritage in your family so it's
like yeah man back in the old country
the weird thing is that so they
overdubbed some of them it's weird
because Clare Higgins who plays Julia
who's her and pinhead are the best
things about this movie I'll say that
right now you know and obviously Doug
Bradley is British but you know it's
like well we have to put an American in
it so the guy they got to play Larry who
actually um Andrew Robinson is an
actor's name he was in [ __ ] goddammit
what was that Clint Eastwood movie he
played a Scorpio he played like the
villain and won in his [ __ ] I don't
know [ __ ] man I can't remember the name
of it right now it's just gone right on
my head but yeah he was in that now he's
an American actor so cuz they wanted an
American in it they let like the other
people be British but then they set it
in some random like they never tell you
like where the setting is it's supposed
to be in the United States but they
don't really say where it is because I
was asking you where the [ __ ] you that's
like where the [ __ ] is this it looked
like Canada I'm pretty sure they shot it
in the UK although what looked like in
the background they showed that building
that that factory off the dam Pink Floyd
album cover looks like a [ __ ] upside
down [ __ ] stacks yeah I saw that so
it must have been England somewhere oh
yeah I think they did shoot it in
England but like I said in you know the
producers were like well we have to just
like set it in a non specific
mid-atlantic us yes
date or something like that it's a weird
it kind of works just because I mean
this movie didn't have like a super high
budget and a lot of it takes place in
one house you know what I mean so
there's not like a lot of extraneous
like sets and [ __ ] like that it's mostly
just this character drama with these
three main characters and this skinless
dude upstairs and you know a lot of it
is kind of set in there so you can tell
that like most of the budget went on the
costumes and the makeup and the special
effects because there's yeah they are
still [ __ ] amazing now the
interesting about the thing about this
is that the cent abates I remember in
the novella because I think that Clive
Barker wrote a couple other he wrote
something called like the Scarlett
gospel I think it was called and then
there was like another Hellraiser later
on where he kind of expanded on the
mythology of them a little bit they were
kind of like this you know this order of
demons like in hell called the order of
the gash or something like that and what
they're just like travelers like I said
through you know they like they say in
the movie where they're just kind of
like they don't they no longer like can
tell the difference between pleasure and
pain anymore
they're not and it's weird and the in
the movie they're not they're set up as
villains but not really because they
only come when you call them yeah and
you call them because you want this
would they have known what they have to
offer this kind of say to masochistic
experience it's like these people that
are like going to extremes and it's like
they've done everything and like they
want yeah this is a this was a ballsy
idea about it was in eight nine eleven
yeah yeah I remember you know just how
we were reacting to the concept of this
where you find this damn box it's like a
puzzle and if you open it up they come
from another dimension
and do this to you you know because they
think you called them and that idea back
in 87 was [ __ ] mind-blowing yeah it's
like it was a revolutionary they said
I'm thinking about that going oh I'm
gonna be some weird [ __ ] you know what I
mean now it is you know it's it doesn't
seem too exciting way everybody so Jade
everybody's jaded now you know the idea
of other dimensions and internet
internet blows away all this [ __ ] but I
love the internet or the imagination it
really did because like back in 87 bobis
yeah it was just kind of like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] you've never seen anything
like this and like I said you never
thought anything like and yeah and
that's that's what I mean that's the
first time that I read Clive Barker when
I was a kid which I think was books of
blood volume one and some of the stories
that he wrote in there I'm like how the
[ __ ] did this duty that think of this
[ __ ] holy crap yeah Internet opened
opened up your mind wide open to all
kinds of weird [ __ ] you could find
anything you just type in a damn Google
search engine back before it was before
it was censored like it is now you'd see
some all kinds of weird [ __ ] and it's
just back 87 that concept that blow your
[ __ ] mind
yeah well and and the thing too is that
I mean when he first conceived the
hellbound heart when he first conceived
this movie his idea going forward was
that the main protagonist and the you
know person that was going to carry
through the series like you know as it
went on was going to be Julia because
she was she's essentially an evil
character she's a horrible [ __ ] I mean
not only she [ __ ] around at her
husband but then she decides oh I love
this dude's dick so much that I'm gonna
kill people so he can have his [ __ ]
skin back and she doesn't like care who
she kills so she gets kind of more and
more evil as it goes on but the
interesting thing about it was then the
move when the movie came out and they
didn't really seem to realize this
before the movie came out when the movie
came out everybody latched on to the
pinhead character just cuz like the land
the Senna bytes in general because
there's like the Chatterer and the one
that they called butterball like the
female with the vagina thing and her
yeah it was kind of position well that's
what the guy said he wanted it to look
like national yeah her voice spot her
voice is coming out of there as weird
but I think it had a lot to do with his
voice his voice he had that because
voice his voice sold that character oh
yeah and made that character into
something that people want to see more
and more of but like I said but by time
movie three camera I you want to see any
more of it yeah I didn't like I said
it's a great concept and it's like it
needed or give the more it has
diminishing returns the more you know
about them the less you know less
mystery they have so you're like uh
that's all it is yeah I was yeah and in
general I think that's true with any
horror franchise and I think that's why
that's part of the main reason why
sequels tend to get worse and worse as
they go on is that you know you have
something as cool as the Cenobites
and you just get little snippets they
don't really say like they appear every
now and then and he says you know demons
to some angels to others you know you
called us we came should never explain
and they just like yeah just don't
explain it it's you know what I mean
it's it the more it goes on it's not
cool but like I said amazingly this was
Doug Bradley's first movie now I was
watching the Leviathan documentary
earlier today and he gave a very
interesting anecdote he said since this
was my first movie and he knew Clive
from the stage acting that they had done
prior and he said well he said my agent
said well you can either have the the
lead Santa bite part or you can be one
of the guys that that when they were
moving in at the beginning one of the
guys that was helping them move the
mattress up the stairs and he said for a
few minutes I kind of thought maybe I
should be the mattress guy because
no because you'll be able to see my face
oh he said because this is my first
movie and I want to be able to like
point--is and I don't want to be like
under all this makeup and you don't
recognize me
you know what I mean so he's like so I
did think about it for a few minutes
that it's like maybe I should be that
guy so I just looked like a regular
person instead of like a monster I made
the right decision but then yeah other
than that and it's just it's funny
because he seems like he'd had been
forgotten yeah he seems like he seems
like a really cool guy and it like I
said he played pinhead in like seven or
eight of the subsequent movies made a
whole career and he made a whole like
career of it but you know as you said
had he not played that character with
that [ __ ] voice that he has never
would have I don't think that this movie
would have been I think it would have
still been iconic because the effects
are great the I know their concepts but
the fact that it's still so me beable
the fact that people know the puzzlebox
they know pinhead they know lines from
the movie even if they haven't seen it
in years and yet those sequels and that
wouldn't have happened yeah if it wasn't
for her they would have they just
wouldn't Ben is good yeah because the
sequels were all built around that damn
character oh yeah a character and so it
was carrying that whole it was carried
that whole [ __ ] series but you know
some some dudes just want to keep going
down in a path and know more and more
and they get all off into it some people
like me you know knowing too much spoils
it they should have never explained
those characters [ __ ] I don't think they
should have ever given any backgrounds
yeah it seemed mystifies life and like I
said and I've mentioned this many times
before but it's like horror especially
as a genre that thrives on mystery and
out of the unknown and the more you know
about something the less scary it is um
you know I'm Celeste interesting yeah
and the less interest you know you have
to have some mystery some intrigue some
kind of thing like other of the
otherwise it's just gonna become boring
and it's just gonna be you know routine
and like everything else but yeah
there's some like [ __ ] Doug Bradley
has some great you know stories about
like doing them because obviously the
makeup was like really intense and it's
like a lot of them like he could see
mostly but he had like this black
contacts but he could barely see and he
had like that big long leather thing and
it's like he didn't really know he was
gonna get
tripping on it [ __ ] but some of the
other like the other Cenobites like the
Chatterer and stuff like he couldn't see
anything yeah I know I like the guy that
was in that and the guy that played
butter ball that had like the sunglasses
and stuff he couldn't really see either
so they were just kind of like having to
push him into place and being like hey
action and you have to think that like
this was this this movie was like the
first movie for a lot of these actors
they had done stage [ __ ] and like you
know things like that but this was like
their first kind of big movie and like I
said even though it costs like less than
a million dollars but ended up making a
[ __ ] sound of correspond tons and tons
and tons of sequels now ever since going
back to like the mid-2000s I believe
they've been talking about doing of
course a remake um that's because they
can't come up with anything but it
hasn't come to fruition thankfully
mostly because all of the directors that
they've asked to do it are like well we
eat we don't want to do it exactly like
the original we just want to like one
idea that I heard that they just wanted
to like expand on the puzzle box like
the lament configuration and wanted to
go in like a different direction every
single director that they had attached
was like we do not want to do a teen
horror movie we do not want to do a
pg-13 we want to do something more in
the spirit of Clive Barker's original
and we want Clive Barker's okay on it
otherwise we don't want to do it so
they've gone through like two or three
different directors and because of
course the producers want to make it a
[ __ ] pg-13 like they did with [ __ ]
the Friday the 13th remake and I think
the nightmare and I'm sure you remake
the prom night remake all that kind of
[ __ ] they want to make the main
characters teenagers and also the kind
of [ __ ] which is just not ain't gonna
fly it is just not what the spirit of
Hellraiser what I mean when you see the
original movie even like the youngest
character um you know [ __ ] Kirsty
who's played by Ashley Lawrence she's
not a teenager she's like in her 20s
and all adults it's all about adults
these problems all might be sorted out
now that this [ __ ] pandemics happened
I mean the big big-money players can't
make horror movies they just can't
because like you said they wanted to do
PG because they think they'll get more
people I see it or good PG
movies don't get me wrong it depends
what kind of horror movie it is but
Hellraiser the whole thing is about
sadomasochism eroticism gore they're
focused on theatres and ticket sales how
many people can be in seats that's
already gonna [ __ ] you got to worry
about it is it's got to be something
that will it sell on streaming well yeah
I'll get it on screening and if it's on
streaming you want it to be our yeah you
know [ __ ] the theater that that that's
when it comes to movies like this I
think that's that games played out well
and [ __ ] remaking horror movies I mean I
can see more along the lines of making
remaking something like Friday the 13th
with teenage characters cuz that's kind
of what the original was like but
Hellraiser was essentially an
adult-oriented domestic drama with
sadomasochism and gore elements and a
lot of eroticism too which was taken out
Clive Barker thought that was very funny
that he's like there were a couple of
like the flashback scenes like with
Frank and Julia characters he's like I
had some really like really sexually
like charged like kind of [ __ ] you know
with some anal and everything and of
course like the MPA was like oh no you
can't do that but they thought but it
was fine for like for them to do blood
like and you know when they're having
sex like him with a knife and everything
I got oh the violence is fine but it's
like he's like the MPAA told him he's
like you can have two male thrusts but
three is obscene
now some of the gore has been taken out
to like the the very end scene where
Frank wearing Larry's skin where he gets
pulled apart by all the hooks and like
says that great line jesus wept which
was apparently that actor's ad-lib yeah
he was supposed to just say [ __ ] you and
the actor was like that seemed kind of
lame he's like so he just said that
instead and Clive was like oh yeah
that's awesome so there was a there was
a longer kind of that like when his when
his head exploded some of the kill
scenes where Julia is killing the random
dudes like with the hammer and stuff
that there was a lot more gore there and
they took trimmed a little bit of that
out and like I said they do ticket they
took out some of the because I think
one of those scenes like the guy the guy
who was being murdered wanted to be
naked because he's like well it makes
more sense because I think I'm gonna get
laid and then she turns around and
whacks in the head with a hammer so they
shot it both ways but like I said they
thought there was too much nudity in it
they thought there was too much
eroticism in it they you know so a lot
of that got cut out [ __ ] that's what
I mean so
se5 was like Clive was like there was
some great spanking scenes with Frank
and Juliet it's like I don't know what
happened to them we shot up please
what's funny is they want to make a
[ __ ] hundred million dollars wrap up
two hundred million dollars in the
production of a movie so they can make a
billion dollars
that's just not going to happen and and
Hellraiser it wasn't a success because
of box office sales I don't think it
made all that much money to box on well
it did but that's because it didn't cost
that much yeah but it was but what it
yielded wasn't really much it was only
you know a profit yeah I didn't make a
whole lot of money at the theater it
made me it's money and at the video
rental store yeah everybody wanted to
see that is every boy that had a like
[ __ ] huge I think it made 15 mil in
the theaters like I said it cost a
little less than a million dollars to
make so it made like wave yeah fifty
million times it's if you lunge it back
you release something like that today
that's what it would make probably in
the theatre yeah you know you got to go
for streaming streaming as today's
version of video rental and I always
feel like if you're gonna make a horror
movie make a [ __ ] horror make a
[ __ ] horror movie don't stick around
don't do I don't see the point you know
like I said I've seen a lot of really
good pg-13 horror movies don't get me
wrong it can be done well but if you're
gonna do a slasher movie for example or
something like Hellraiser pg-13 it gonna
cut it because what the whole reason
that people go see movies like that is
largely for the gore and you know to see
a lot of the practical effects if you're
just gonna cut away every time somebody
gets killed what's the [ __ ] point of
watch it in Studios Hollywood studios
they only make money I mean they only
make movies to make a bunch of money on
turnaround on opening night that's all
they care a big boom on opening night
they're not patient they don't give a
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] video sales they
don't we don't have time for that or
like for it to build up into a cult
pirate or something like most profitable
movie of
all times this second road warrior Mad
Max road Wars yeah I don't think this
meeting spend much money on it but over
time it's just like cards of millions
hundreds of millions of dollars that
thing is made on video rattles the
streamings and it took a long time for
it to reach that amount but I think it's
the last I checked it was the most
profitable movie in history yeah I feel
like you know I know you can say it's
you know the studio's there's in the
business to make money so they want
their you know they want their
investment back like with the whole days
within a couple days they don't really
have time to like dig around and see
like oh you know the movie comes out
nobody sees it but then 10 years later
everybody's like oh it's a classic and
now it's making money because everybody
wants to see it but well their support
and all these people inside that
industry and all their mansions they got
a lot of debts to pay you know the idea
of taking three million dollars making a
movie and stream it and in four in four
days make ten million dollars and that's
a [ __ ] ton of money that that's not
that's not enough for them yeah but like
I said earlier when I was we were doing
side tracks it's now opened up for the
little guy yeah you know what tonight
like I said I feel like it's been going
in that direction in the last 10 20
years anyway we're in the punk rock face
of the of them yeah it's definitely the
way I why type of that's right doing it
yourself and making small productions
and stream and I'm in making a making a
name for yourself with a cool movie with
original content and it didn't cost much
to make and you did it your way and [ __ ]
what the studio says and [ __ ] whether
it's just your movie that's really gonna
be the future and yeah and that
definitely applies to Hellraiser because
he Clive Barker wrote the [ __ ] story
he's like I want to make a movie out of
it he was able to secure you know maybe
only a million bucks or something like
that but he made a movie that people
still talk about nowadays that people
everybody knows who [ __ ] pinhead is
like I said even if people that aren't
into horror movies if you show them a
picture of pinhead or over the puzzlebox
everybody knows what the [ __ ] that is
right I am a million dollar movie yeah
and you can't really say that about a
lot of movies think of all the
merchandising that was sold on the back
of that shirts and little [ __ ]
autographed pictures and
and like I said [ __ ] Doug Bradley his
whole [ __ ] career is just just
because he came out like with this he
was in the movie for maybe 10 minutes
came out in that [ __ ] makeup and that
[ __ ] voice and that was it like you
know that was just kind of like and like
I said he wasn't even supposed to be the
main thrust of that movie they were just
kind of supposed to kind of be in the
background type of thing they weren't
supposed to be the main characters Julia
was supposed to be the main character
she was in the second movie you know she
got brought back because she died at the
end of the first one but um but you know
they can bring you back with the blood
and everything and the horror scene is
like a cult II to begin with yeah put
put out a good horror movie it was
you're an actor you'll be able to do
[ __ ] conventions for the rest of your
life yeah and we've mentioned that
Nathan before yeah yeah like the woman
who played Jason's mom she did always
classy flicks when she got older they
were all forgotten but what she
remembered what was that memory was her
being Jason's mom well yeah forties the
funny was her a whole [ __ ] job is to
be an old lady in that damn sweater and
signing autographs and entertaining it
the damn and she had a life yeah she was
making money off of that yeah you know
and being able to pay bills all those
big high-class movies that she had made
what was her name again Betsy Palmer
Betsy Palmer yeah she made a bunch of
high-class movies in the 60s and [ __ ]
those were all long forgotten and they
stopped paying the bills well yeah
horror is really where it's at
turns okay like I said an eye for dollar
that's worth it I'm glad that like kind
of you know the stigma about horror
isn't really around anymore like it was
back in the old days and it's funny that
you mentioned her thing because Andrew
Robinson the guy that plays Larry and
Hellraiser he said a very similar thing
in the Leviathan documentary he said you
know when I was in this movie he's like
I've done Shakespeare and all this other
stuff he's like my daughter she didn't
she was like [ __ ] that and she didn't
care about the movie she's like he's
like but when I was in Hellraiser I was
like cool dad because it's like all I
heard all her friends wanted to see that
[ __ ] yeah just the other day we saw a
really cool you know crustle movie
called what was a breakdown yeah and
break it down with a [ __ ] great movie
kind of like The Hitcher or duel duel
but it's forgotten yeah forgot know it
was really successful it was successful
at the time they made money on it but it
was like a flash in the pan
forgotten had that been a horror
equivalent movie crustle still be going
to the damn horror conventions you know
I'm only [ __ ] sign and all kinds
autographs it's like I said if you want
to like make a [ __ ] ton of money then
mate well maybe maybe don't do horror
movies but if you want to be an actor
and you want to be remembered forever
and adored forever do horror or sci-fi
yeah and you will have a [ __ ] career
forever out of that you the only
obstacle in horror movies is the writing
it's got to be a badass story with some
new ideas in it and that's kind of hard
so you have to go back to like
tried-and-true methods you know I mean
and good writing and good characters and
a good monster and a good twist on
something with a good score and you just
try to make it classic yeah you know I
like it too it's now that you mentioned
score is actually I'm glad you mentioned
that because I wanted to to mention this
the score for Hellraiser was actually
done by Christopher Young who I think it
done Freddy's dead the second Nightmare
on Elm Street but originally Clive
Barker wanted to do wanted the band coil
to do the music yeah I remember that
which would have been really cool
because I love [ __ ] fell through for
some reason it did well they had a
meeting them and Christopher young and
they kind of had a thing and I think
Christopher Young actually ended up
using some of their ideas like and
acknowledging that but I think yeah
there was some kind of thing they
couldn't come to an agreement or
whatever because Clive Barker was
friends with them and he was really like
a big fan of their work and stuff so he
wanted them to score the movie but for
whatever reason it didn't work out which
like I said I like Christopher young
score for this but it's kind of a shame
cuz I really really like coy I'll put a
whole new spin and I would have yet I
would have liked to have heard what they
could do like with this type of movie
because this is very much in line with
in real industrial with that type of
yeah like the [ __ ] that was going on at
the time and like a prototype of a Nine
Inch Nails video it would have been it
probably would have looked exactly like
that but yeah so I encourage you if you
have not seen hell raiser for a very
long time or if you've never seen it cuz
like I said it keeps oh we have some
younger people and maybe you haven't
seen it because it came out so long ago
in 1987 yeah then definitely check it
out it's a classic like I said the
second one I remember the second one
being really good I saw that several
times I haven't seen it for several
years but I saw it on cable like a lot
back in the old days I saw the third one
but I don't remember anything about it
and I don't think that I saw any of the
other ones subsequently and I heard that
they went downhill like I said I don't
usually I don't usually hang in there we
I mean we watched all the phantasm
movies and those are all those are all
stronger is the only oddly is the only
horror series that I've ever seen that
actually got stronger as it went and
that they they had so many movies that
were consistently yeah diesel like every
single wonderful was decent it was the
same guy making them yeah they were hand
they were handcrafted he cared about it
and he kept upping the ante and up in
the Andy and doing it his way and really
the the one the worst one was the one
that had a real studio behind it and it
wasn't that bad
was probably the part - I like that one
there's nobody that was the first one
that I saw I saw that in the theater but
the other the ones that he made where I
think we're better there were a lot more
purity in than my face well you can go
weird get he got weirder right and
winter is usually better yeah well at
the end it's like Mad Max end of the
world him against the demons and [ __ ]
and gotta love Reggie yeah demons Reggie
and and demons from another dimension
yeah that's pretty cool I know I want to
see that one again I know I think well I
think shudder has three four and five
and maybe the first one I don't really
remember now a shudder like I said it
also has it has the first Hellraiser in
the second Hellraiser and it also has
that two-part documentary called
Leviathan it's very long I think it's
about three hours like the first parts
of hour and a half and just talks about
hell raiser
then the second part talks about Hell
bound and that's another hour and a half
I didn't use fire me not only not only
do I want a [ __ ] Neville action
figure I wanna I want no actions you
want a Reggie bad starchy action figure
with his ice with an ice cream truck ice
cream truck I bet you could buy one now
I want to I want to like the the final
Reggie yeah like from like from ravager
or whatever avenger' right longer he's
always gonna kind of go on Mad Max
it'll be pretty cool he's such a great
[ __ ] like the mossad [ __ ] the most
unlikely like
or hero ever yeah no but imagine I have
to look somebody must be making one yeah
that I would think that somebody was it
might be like I'm sure it's
limited-edition right but every other
[ __ ] character has been covered
I like surprise like some those customs
guys are making though I think they're
like a 12-inch doll yeah it's like a GI
Joe and everything and you know they're
doing they're doing you know like
mistake Plissken and they're doing
Neville from a Mega Man and I'd like to
have a Reggie like that so it's like a
it's like a GI Joe doll yeah to be
awesome with the guns and everything
that would be pretty cool yeah they're
making them it's just like I think
they're made on like like kind of like
we can buy like a generic doll and it
bought yeah and then you can buy people
are [ __ ] handcrafted in the heads
yeah yeah just to put on it that way
you're not violating or maybe you are
violating copyrights but no I don't
think so you're assembling it yourself
yeah I think I'm always kind of wondered
about what the legality of that is
because you're you got a doll's head
that has suck and you know the main
crustle space on it yeah you know it I
guess it's just bootleg people making it
it's gotta be because like I mean actors
as far as I know particularly one of
like you know yeah calibers Kurt Russell
you know should you be able to get there
yeah like you can't use their image raw
thing that's like evidently people are
breaking those rules in in that action
figure self a custom action figure maybe
if you make it like look 30% like
someone other than Kurt Russell you can
get away with it I don't know a lot of
this [ __ ] that it's made out of it's
just a standard body yeah their columns
are made it the costumes are made out of
just replicas of [ __ ] that they bought
out of the store anyway you know I mean
when they made the movie like the
terminators the Terminator costume you
could buy that back then in those days
that was just a jacket in the right pan
my dad had those boots well you can buy
those boots for action figures yes
that's just because you put it together
to look like the Terminator that doesn't
mean you did that you're not selling it
right you know I mean and each each
component was bought separately yeah I
mean I think you obviously I think you
would get in trouble if you were like
selling it or like making a profit off
it yeah you could probably get away with
it if you sold it for exactly what
you mate you spent making it if it's a
one-of-a-kind because you're not fitting
yeah and it's not a package it's not in
a box you know it's weird cuz I see a
lot of horror stuff and it's like I
always wonder like is that violating
copyright yeah maybe there's so much of
it that they just can't can't control it
control it or keep up with it I don't
know I don't know but yeah so anyway if
you haven't seen it like I said both the
the first two are on shudder as is the
three hour long documentary thanks again
to Dominic for sending me
they're really nice special edition
blu-ray I'm watching all the extra [ __ ]
on there as we speak not as we speak but
you know over the last few days I've
been watching all the extra [ __ ] on
there so yeah check it out